There have been some genuinely bad numbers
for Donald Trump since the Ukraine fiasco
started, but we may have gotten the worst
one yet yesterday, and it is that North Carolina
Republicans are bailing on Trump since the
Ukraine scandal and the impeachment inquiry
started understand that in the last nine of
10 presidential elections, North Carolina
has been strongly Republican.
There is a new Meredith poll were Trump's
North Carolina approval is down to 39.9% now
you might hear me say 39.9% and you would
correctly say, David, that doesn't sound that
low because nationally Donald Trump has been
sort of hovering between 37 and 43 for his
entire presidency.
39.9 doesn't seem like a big deal, but understand
that this is specifically North Carolina.
Trump's Republican approval in North Carolina
is down by more than 13% from 86 to 74 not
13 percentage points.
It's down 12 percentage points, which is 13%
please don't email me about the math confusion
that sometimes happens.
North Carolina is the prototypical center,
right?
But solidly Republican state, which could
be a bellwether in 2020 you go back to 1980
North Carolina has gone to the Republican
in the presidential every single time, except
in 2008 when Barack Obama won it.
It was very close.
In 2016 Trump defeated Hillary in North Carolina
by only three and a half percentage points
in 2016 there already wasn't much of a margin
for error for Trump and North Carolina in
2016 so when you see his support among Republicans
dropping in the state and driving down the
overall approval rating for Trump in North
Carolina, you quickly realize that if these
numbers don't turn around, it does not bode
particularly well for Donald Trump.
So here's my outlook for the 2020 electorial
college because we often dig into the polls
and we don't necessarily zoom out and look
at what it might mean.
Bigger picture.
Donald Trump has been incorrectly touting
that in 2016 he had some massive records setting
electorial college when he didn't, but Trump
and some other acolytes are starting to talk
about, Hey, you know what?
We might win 40 we might win 42 States or
more in 2020 now it sounds crazy and it probably
is, but there's another side to that coin.
If you look back at 2016 Trump won, I believe
it's 30 States.
Lots of those States were razor thin margins
and Trump still lost the popular vote by almost
3 million votes.
Pennsylvania was the 0.7% margin.
A Florida was a 1.2% margin.
Michigan was a 0.3% margin.
Wisconsin was a 0.7% margin.
North Carolina, as I told you, was about three
and a half percentage points.
This could go the exact opposite way in 2020
and the Delta, meaning the shift from 2016
need only be very small for that to happen.
A few percentage point shift in approval away
from Trump.
Enough, a handful or even two or three of
these key States such that some Republicans
decide to vote third party, some Republicans
vote for a Democrat.
You don't even need that many to do that.
Some Republicans choose to just stay home.
That could flip three, four, or five States
easily as a starting point.
But once again, we can't control that.
We need to work on what can we control, which
is our turnout.
If Republicans help us along because they
either choose to stay home or some we'll vote
for a Democrat, uh, or some of them will vote
third party all the better.
It just helps the numbers.
But when you see these numbers in North Carolina
and you go back to 2016 and you look at the
razor thin margins in some States, if Donald
Trump cannot maintain or regain some of this
Republican approval in these key States, it
is trouble for him.
But it is only trouble if we get out and vote.
And I apologize, I know I'm a broken record
on this, but all of this analysis does not
matter if our side doesn't come out and vote.
That's just the math of it and that's why
it's so important to understand that even
with low approval rating, if we don't vote,
Donald Trump can still get himself reelected.
Some of your thoughts, we are on Facebook
at facebook.com/david Pakman show.
We will take a quick break.
We do need to address a lot of you emailed
me and you that you said I wouldn't talk about
it, but I'm going to.
Elizabeth Warren
has a toxic racist, homophobic surrogate.
I talked about Bernie's toxic surrogate.
I'm going to talk a little bit about Elizabeth
Warren's right after the break